we imagine a future
and our imaginings horrifice
in the case of this film I wrote the
script in the first person it's the only
time I've done that it made it clear to
anyone who read the script that we're on
this ride with Oppenheimer it was very
unusual it took me a minute to actually
comprehend and then I realized oh that's
a huge responsibility I don't know if we
can be trusted but I know the Nazis
can't Killian playing Oppenheimer was
the centerpiece of the film but I knew
that he was going to need the most
extraordinary Ensemble around him let's
go recruit some scientists
if Chris Nolan calls you and says that
he'd like to meet with you like I don't
care what it is you'd be mad to say no
and
and yeah I feel like that's probably
everybody's answer with this from the
second I read the script I knew that he
had a very acute vision and if he were
able to render that Vision that this
film would be a masterpiece all
America's industrial night and
scientific innovation connected here
keep everyone there until it's done it
feels to me every single character is
significant because they're all
historical figures of consequence
there's a chance when we push that
button we destroy the world chances are
near zero
they tried to familiarize myself with
Groves and the history and then talked
to Chris about what he needed from that
part Groves it was almost like a
kindergarten teacher in some respects
because these scientists were so
eccentric and not necessarily
trustworthy I mean if you're looking
from a military perspective why would we
go to the middle of nowhere for who
knows how long why how about because
this is the most important thing that
ever happened in the history of the
world I was aware of who Louis straws
was I came to have a pretty even-handed
understanding of him he was a righteous
guy I think it was a great public
servant but he's always behind the
scenes I've always appreciated the
people who are backstage Truman needs to
know what's next what's next with Kitty
Oppenheimer what I really was drawn to
is she refused to conform to the sort of
feminine ideal of the time she had this
Defiance against the system that felt so
modern Jean catalog was blunt knew what
she wants but at no is she ever punished
for that and especially not by
Oppenheimer Theory will take you only so
far Oppenheimer sees things in sort of
different dimensions physicists operate
on a completely different level than we
do and I think sometimes it's a burden
so I was really interested in that
what we were looking for was a
remarkably centered performance the
heart of the film but also an ensemble
piece why was there on set every day
surrounded by a team of actors who knew
more than I did about what was going on
from their point of view and that's what
you're really looking for as a director
it's a profoundly moving and
overwhelming experience watching it
because you feel so compelled to watch
what's happening with these people and
how they're drawn into the biggest of
moral dilemmas and what they're
wrestling with all of the characters
with the sound design and the school and
the emotionality of it this is not a
film this is an experience
when I saw it in its finished form
I was kind of like
wow yeah that's what we were hoping this
could be the world will remember this
day
[Music]